hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easy jammen wir
sind heute im wunderbaren wien mit
matthias und einem ganzen haufen easy
german zuschauer die heute zu unserem
meetup gekommen sind
matthias wir werden jetzt mal hier im
museumsquartier herumgehen und ich habe
mal eine frage ausgedacht die mich
persönlich sehr stark interessiert
und zwar was denken die österreicher
über deutsche und du stellst mir jetzt
gott die frau oder soll ich nur auf die
idee deiner frage hat ein film ist das
in tallinn das ganze suppe geben auch
ganz gespannt welche antworten bekommen
und ich weiß jetzt schon wir werden
überrascht sein
gut dann fangen wir mal an interviews
so ein zufall museumsquartier in wien da
trifft man immer noch von dir wissen
wollte was denkst du eigentlich über
deutsche über deutsche
ich mag die deutschen wirklich unser
fragen wir heute was denken die
österreicher wieder deutschen ganz
spontan unsere heutige frage ist was
denken die österreicher wie die
deutschen
deutschland ist ja wunderschön oder
deutschen dieser schönes land wenn wir
nicht so viele deutsche beginnen zumal
der hauptteil meiner freunde ist super
das heißt in wirklichkeit gibt es dann
keine großen unterschiede oder er schon
nur unterschiede
ich liebe die differenz in der sprache
und vom ausdrücke ja super vielen dank
und generell gibt es irgendwo negative
stimmung naja oder er postet die firma
die negative stimmung
deswegen versuche ich das alles
wiedergutzumachen positiver super das
ist bei fällt vielen dank man sagt immer
dass die österreicher zur hölle sich
raufen uns gibt es aber weniger die es
in deutschland ja ich habe sowohl auf
meinem rasmus semester als auch in
meiner wg immer ganz viele deutsche
freunde gefunden ja und könnte auch
leute die die deutschen nicht nur ich
bin in österreich klar aber es ist immer
so eine ein liebevolles nicht mögen
immerhin nicht mögen mit einem
augenzwinkern
ja das ist es wirklich ist ja es ist so
ein vieh zelebrieren diese hassliebe und
dass wir wollen einfach diese kultur
dass witze darüber reißens oder schnee
wie man den winter nicht nicht missen
und da ich bin dann am stolzesten
österreicher wenn ihr mit einem
deutschen reeder
was bewegt habe habe ich auf meiner
staatsbürgerschaft das fällt mir im
ersten
zu einer super sie sprechen schon super
danke
wir sind natürlich zwei völker die die
gleiche sprache sprechen so dass wir
natürlich uns viel besser verständigen
könnten
wenn wir uns gegenseitig auch weiter
öffnen würden und du als deutscher du
wohnst ja hast hast du mit vorurteilen
manchmal zu tun
nicht wirklich ernst gemeinten also ist
schwingt schon irgendwie immer mit den
so alltäglichen sachen aber es ist nie
ernst gemeint richtig also ich bin nie
wirklich ernsthaft diskriminiert worden
oder auf mich ich komme aus deutschland
ich würde gerne wissen was österreich
über deutsche denken sie sind pünktlich
straight was noch
streng was vielleicht genauer blick ganz
kurz und war die frage heute stellen ist
was denken die österreicher über die
deutschen
ich komme aus schottland was denken was
denken sie über die deutschen dann
stellst besser
was jetzt eigentlich gehört das ist auch
so ein bisschen deutsche auch nicht
mögen
das ist ein mieter fall matthias ein
kurzes zwischenfazit wie lieferservice
her
ja ich bin's bezeichnen alle merken die
deutschen aber haben trotzdem immer
wieder mal vor schenkelklopfer und
augenzwinkern dabei die vorurteile
gegenüber deutschen im skiurlaub
betrinken sie sich kennen wir kennen
ihre alkoholischen grenzen nicht und
blockieren die piste gar nichts sie
rasen auf der autobahn halten sie sich
an die geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen die
es bei uns gibt
ich mag die deutschen also ich mag die
deutschen aber im fußball
ich hoffe ihr gewinnt nicht die em und
das ist das ist kein vorteil dass es
sich auch bei meinen deutschen freunden
in österreich leider lernen musste
selbst wenn sie in österreich leben sie
informieren sich nicht über
österreichische gesellschaftliche
vorkommnisse sie haben keinen plan von
österreichischer politik kollegen was es
ist einfach das kleine falls land ich
lebte zwar aber ich informiere mich
trotzdem über deutsche politik und nicht
über österreichische und hast du
vielleicht vorteile gegenüber deutschen
naja ich bin ich aufgewachsen in wien
also österreicherinnen und ich glaube
schon dass das so in meinem umfeld
reigen die das deutsche sieht kann mich
mein vater immer geschimpft auf deutsche
autofahrer merkt man sich das braucht
seine zeit lang aber ich bin jetzt mit
einem deutschen zusammen und es ist eine
hassliebe
ich habe das gefühl das deutsche recht
viel reden und dann werfen wir uns immer
gegenseitig vorrede zu fehlern ich bin
halt die kanzlerin die ewig schweiz
vorurteile sag ich mal
man sagt dass die österreicher ich sage
mal in ihrer meinung ein bisschen länger
und das heißt sie mögen sich nicht gerne
entscheiden das heißt mögen ein bisschen
ja schauen wir mal vielleicht eine im
ungefähren bleiben
so werden der deutsche ja natürlich dann
in der regel immer eine meinung hat er
sagt meistens geradeaus links oder
rechts
er gibt die richtung vor jetzt noch mal
für die die es nicht kennen das wort
piefke beschreiben eigentlich nett
gemeintes schimpfwort deutsche aber ich
weiß nicht gar nicht was es heißt also
logisch weil sich gar nicht woher rührt
seit einfach von
musiker von gebildeten salzburg oder
wenn ich mich nicht täusche der
deutscher gewesen ist salzburg ist
beliebt war und dann hat sich das
irgendwie durchgesetzt weil der piefke
hieß dass andere leute dann auch briefe
waren aber ich bin mir nicht
100-prozentig sicher ob das stimmt dass
aufgaben für euch zum recherchieren wo
kommt das wort
die österreicher sind etwas gemütlicher
würde ich sagen von der grundeinstellung
die deutschen ein bisschen strater und
ein bisschen nüchterner die österreicher
dafür tendenzielle bisschen negativer
die deutschen etwas ambitionierter ich
weiß nicht ich finds sympathisch taktik
klar schnell unsere heutige frage ist
was denken die österreicher über die
deutschen
dass wir grundsätzlich immer gegen sie
gewinnen sollten passiert vor allen
dingen zu oft für österreich oft genug
das muss man jetzt auf jeden fall ein
fast schon gesagt werden muss ist dass
wir ganz viele deutsche migranten in
österreich haben als der größte anteil
an ausländer in österreich sind deutsche
und vor allen dingen an den
universitäten kommst du immer wieder zu
missverständnissen zu kulturellen weil
wir denn die deutschen kommen aus
österreich und glauben das ist dieselbe
kultur und außer einer gemeinsamen
sprache ist dann nicht so viel gemeinsam
also wir haben schon unterschiedliche
art und das kennt manchmal zu konflikten
führen aber trotzdem immer nur mit einem
augenzwinkern sagt ein beispiel also
richtiges beispiel was man immer wieder
auffällt ist kellner bringt ein falsches
getränk an den tisch österreicher wird
da nichts sagen und egal welches gelernt
das ist das trinken
der deutsche wird sofort darauf bestehen
dass das richtige getränk kommen hörer
selbstverständlich naja aber der kann ja
mal fehler machen und dann etwas anderes
aber ansonsten denke ich mal sind 42
zwei völker die gern miteinander
harmonieren die auch glaube ich gut
feiern
die natürlich auch beide gut fußball
spielen können
auch wenn der heutige abend leider nicht
so schnell ausgegangen ist wie sich das
wie man sich das hier so erhofft hat
aber auch hier heißt es dann wieder wenn
man nicht schon gut im fußball ist dann
kann man natürlich auch viel besser ski
fahren
deswegen kann man viele andere sachen
einfach in den vordergrund stellen so
dass die andere situation
denn überhaupt extrem in den hintergrund
rutschen wird und sonst irgendwelche
großen unterschiede zwischen österreich
und deutschland dringend noch spontan
ich hab mir gehen sie emotioneller an
deutschland ist es gewohnt zu gewinnen
österreich hofft dass wir gewinnen
ja liebe zuschauer das war unsere neue
folge ist german aus dem museumsquartier
in wien
zu guter letzt was hast du vielleicht
noch einen witz über die deutschen und
österreichischen witz also witz
vielleicht der kurze nicht nur wenn wir
ist recht auf urlaub fahren und sollten
gegebenfalls man unangenehm auffallen
warum auch immer passieren
sorgen wir auf jeden fall wird an
deutsche was steht mir wohl so vor
ja danke euch fürs zuschauen wir hoffen
sehr dass euch diese episode mit
matthias unseren ganzen zuschauern ja
nicht kannst du einmal 360 grad dich
bewegen sie wollten alle nicht auf die
kamera aber tatsächlich das sind all
unsere zuschauer die hier zu unserem
meeting gekommen sind
nach wien und wir sagen danke nein
christel schon unbedingt müsst ihr abi
der unbedingt muss die uns abonnieren
und hier könnt ihr uns unterstützen und
wir freuen uns sehr über eure
unterstützung danke und bis zum nächsten
mal